hello everyone in the previous two
videos I had discussed the importance of
problem solving and in this video I'm
going to discuss something which is even
more important than problem solving
something which should come even before
problem solving but before we can get
into that discussion let me begin
today's session with something little
bit different so consider the following
sentences the first sentence the sun
rises in the east
consider the second sentence there is
strength in
unity and consider the third sentence
divide and
conquer well you may think have I gone
crazy what's so special about these
three sentences well all throughout this
discussion I'm going to discuss certain
things which will T directly to these
three very simple very
apparently uh absolutely simple
sentences and you will see that there is
a lot more to unpack even in the simple
message of these three sentences and
just to keep things a little bit
interesting consider a bonus fourth
sentence I am 32 and my girlfriend is
13 well you don't have to go and report
to the police this is a sentence I have
picked up from the reddit website and
I'm going to come back to it again tying
in to the message that I'm trying to
give in this video all right so let us
begin this video in
Earnest so as I was saying I'm going to
discuss something which is even more
foundational than problem solving what
is it this is the aptitude to learn by
oneself sounds very boring right but
this is something which if you lose this
opportunity to learn by oneself if you
lose this during your school life
although it is not completely
irreversible but it is tremendously
consequential for your further studies
especially when you go to your plus two
when there is a massive jump in the
level from class 10 to class 11 and
certainly when you go to a university
level education and if you if you wish
to go for high studies this is of
tremendous tremendous importance so in
this video what I'm going to do is first
of all discuss why you need to learn by
oneself why do you need to develop this
aptitude and then I'm going to discuss
based on proper scientific evidence and
research which has been done for over 30
40 years 50 years even more than that
actually some of the things which you
can keep in mind to develop this ability
this aptitude to learn by
oneself all right so let us begin why
you need to learn by oneself by yourself
well the first thing is that there will
be certain talk topics all throughout
your life whether it is part of your
formal education or as part of your need
or your desire to learn anything new you
may find that there is no teacher around
to teach you that particular topic so
you have to learn it by yourself that is
the most obvious reason the second
reason is that maybe in in a formal
setting you do have a teacher who is
going to who has the responsibility of
teaching you a certain topic but it may
turn out and it does happen in the best
of Institutions and universities that
the teacher is not very good I'm sure
many of you who may be even going to the
best schools in your cities have
encountered this problem that your
teacher is just not good enough next is
even if the teacher is good okay let us
say you are extremely fortunate your
teacher is good even then it may not be
possible for you to learn everything
from your teacher or the teacher may not
have the time and the bandwidth in the
limited scope of the classroom to give
individual attention to you and to help
you learn at your own pace in the style
that you are most comfortable with so
then also you have to learn things on
your
own and finally as I have already said
as you keep on going to higher and
higher classes as you go up in the
academic ladder you have to develop you
have to uh depend on this ability to
learn by oneself because the expectation
in any University in any Institute is
that you are going to pick things up on
your own and this becomes more and more
weighty means that some instruction will
be given to you but the amount of things
which you have to learn by yourself that
is tremendous so what can you do really
what can you do to develop this ability
during your school life the things that
I'm going to discuss it is not just
things which I'm pulling out from a 10
year it is not an opinion piece uh
rather I have actually gone through some
articles and books uh some uh and I've
realized there's a lot of research which
uh people have done so just like you
have people uh doing research in physics
chemistry even in the humanities in
mathematics uh similarly people are have
been doing research a lot of research
actually proper scientific research in
how to develop Educational
Systems so how to develop the the
teaching systems in our schools and
various kind of institutes so one of the
main books which I have followed for
this uh I must give credit where it is
due is uh a very famous book by Daniel
Willingham Professor Daniel Willingham
uh so the book is a little bit funnily
named it is why students don't like
school the first thing which you need to
uh realize and this may sound a little
bit counterintuitive which is uh the
reason I'm making this video is that is
is the importance of memory what I'm
saying here is again backed by research
the research which has been done in the
domain of cognitive science so Professor
Daniel wellingham is actually a
cognitive scientist he has uh he has
compiled the various evidence that says
that yes memory is important now one may
counter argue that okay who is this
Daniel Willingham I know a quotation
from uh none other than Professor
Einstein who has said that imagination
is more important than memory well
true it is important but try to
understand very carefully what he's
saying Professor Einstein that
imagination is more important than
memory it he never said that memory is
not important okay so once you reach a
certain level we have to understand in
the proper context in which him have
said that that once you reach a certain
level in order to create new knowledge
you have to have imag
imagination so we have to understand
things in the proper context but here
what we are trying to discuss
is the importance of memory as part of
our beginning educational Journey as it
is supposed to be done at schools when
you have barely any knowledge and you
are trying to gain acquire the knowledge
as you as you go about this acquisition
at the very very novice level beginning
beginners level it is at that stage that
memory plays a hugely important role
probably much more than even your
teachers have emphasized so there is a
lot of uh uh disparaging
comments regarding Road memorization
which is probably bad but memorization
by itself is not necessarily bad I want
to make this absolutely clear people who
have done research in cognitive science
they have Moralis very nicely and very
firmly established that our human brain
we have a certain amount of working
memory okay so this is the working
memory so this is like uh where you
process
everything starting from the input from
the environment the information that you
have from the environment then you load
into that memory the other bits and
pieces of information which may be
relevant for the discussion or for the
solution of the problem at hand uh from
the deep recesses of your
uh longlasting memory and then you cook
around the various items this input from
the environment and your long-lasting
memories those bits and pieces and then
you try to come up with a solution for
that so all of these things happens in
your working memory but the unfortunate
thing is that our working memory is very
very limited this has been very very
well established and there is not much
variation among the working memory of
various people the normal people okay
I'm not talking about those sants and
those absolute god- gifted
Geniuses what people have actually find
found out is that even a marginal
difference in the cognitive memory in
the working memory of people can play a
big role in bringing about large
differences in the performances and the
learning abilities of individuals so a
little bit of a difference can bring
about a huge difference in the actual
performance so if it is just a little
bit more than a little then imagine how
much uh of a genius a person may turn
out to be so it is like that but the
thing is that our working memory is
limited and it doesn't really I mean
grow as we age so what actually grows is
the the the repository of various bits
and pieces of information that we keep
on acquiring and putting in our
background memory and from which we can
pull in the various kinds of requisite
knowledge into our working memory so as
we grow older we have more experiences
we have more knowledge we can pull in
the requisite information from our
background memory and we can cook better
and we can produce something
better now you may think that what kind
of a abstract discussion is this so let
me go back to that first sentence I told
you at the beginning the sun rises in
the East okay so I'm assuming that you
are something like 145 years old maybe
even a little bit
younger uh so for you this is
almost like a self-evident sentence I
mean there is absolutely nothing special
about it the sun rises in the East but
try to take a step back and try to put
yourself in the shoes of a little kid
maybe a fouryear old a 5-year-old kid
who is just starting to
learn for him or her this sentence is
way too complicated try to think about
it so uh recently my son has started
learning a few English words uh here and
there bits and pieces so uh he can
identify the word the d h e the so if I
show him this sentence the sun rises in
the East for him decoding the fact that
th is the itself is a big achievement he
gets happy just by this achievement th
is the and then he sees Su and son he
identifies that as son and then that is
another major achievement Rises the
moment I say Rises he doesn't he cannot
identify this word but suppose I tell
him that this is
Rises his mind will immediately go to
Something Like Rice bath which we have
for dinner and he gets excited about
dinner because
food so you see where this is going the
sun rises and then maybe he identifies I
and in and then there is another the and
finally when it comes to East e a s East
he has absolutely no idea now you see
decoding the words itself is such a
major achievement for him forget about
the meaning forget about the
comprehension forget about the
implication that this sentence has for
you it is the entire meaning you don't
even have to put any effort to decode
the words it is just self-evident to you
you don't even think twice about it but
for him a four or 5-year-old kid it is
it is extremely extremely hard he has to
decode the word and by the time he has
finished decoding the words he has no
power left in his or no no space left in
his working memory to even go for
a understanding of the meaning of this
in that sentence so you see even for
such a simple sentence there is a lot of
background information which gets loaded
into your working memory for you to
comprehend it and it happens just like
that within a fraction of a second how
did you Reach This stage do you do you
do you decode this entire thing part by
part as I have painstakingly pointed out
to you or do you just take in the entire
meaning automatically so this
automaticity in your comprehension this
fluency of your comprehension has not
happened overnight it has happened as a
result of your acquisition of certain
meanings certain words and a certain
amount of practice that has gone into
comprehending the entire thing now let
me turn the table on you and let me show
you a title of a scientific paper so the
title here says combining mechanical and
chemical effects in the deformation and
failure of a cylindrical electrode
particle in a lithium ion
battery now although you may understand
each and every word that is here in this
title so this is one of my papers uh if
taken together you probably do not
understand what this means furthermore
if you are in let's say class 6 or 7 you
may be a little bit stumped even by that
little combination of the LI which I
read out as lithium and then ion so what
is this lithium you may recognize it as
an element from the periodic table if
you're if you already been exposed to it
but if not that takes some effort so
even though you understand all the words
you may not be able to comprehend the
entire meaning so every time you
encounter something alien you have to in
order to understand it you have to load
background information from your long
memory from your longlasting memory and
then you have to again turn it around in
your working memory to understand it so
memory is very very important the more
memory you have well memory means the
more information that you have more
background information that you have the
better you'll be able to understand
things and the better you you have this
uh this understanding the more you'll be
able to read more and understand more so
it is like a so this development is uh I
don't want to use the word exponential
but in a very lay man's terms it is
exponential it is not linear the more
you learn the the amount of information
which you can acquire gets uh increased
like with tremendous rapidity the next
important thing is the problem with
abstract ideas the way that our
education system is designed you have to
contend with a lot of abstract
ideas so our brain by uh design is not
very good with abstract ideas we are
very good with concrete examples and
this this is not just limited to
mathematics or geometry or science or uh
uh any kind of scientific kind of
knowledge but even even with uh
Humanities kinds of uh topics you have
to content with abstract ideas
so how how do you go about dealing with
this again for this you need to have
some kind of background knowledge uh how
do how do you go about developing this
background knowledge how do you uh how
do you connect this background knowledge
to the abstract ideas well you have to
expose yourself to lots of different
examples but then there is the problem
that just because you have exposed
yourself to um different examples it
doesn't necessarily mean that your your
conception of the concrete uh example
and the conception of the abstract idea
can be transferred to a new situation
let me give you an example so
remember that second sentence I told you
there is strength in unity all of you
understand this as 14y old 15y old
students this is this strength in unity
this is an abstract
concept let me try to give you an
example of a problem which you which you
will face in transfer in in another
context so there is this example which
Professor Willingham mentions this's
this medical problem that there's a
tumor in the body and there is a way to
destroy that tumor by pointing some
special kinds of rays at the tumor but
the problem is that the tumor is
embedded within the body and if you pass
too strong a ray into the body the path
that will take through the body through
the healthy tissues of the body it is
also going to burn up those tissues so
if you make it too strong in strong
enough to destroy the tumor it'll also
in the process destroy all the healthy
tissues what can you
do and you may be thinking so why why am
I mentioning all of this just after that
strength and unity the kind of
abstraction that I'm talking about here
has two steps first of all the
abstraction is you have to reverse your
thinking so there is strength in unity
what was the third sentence I mentioned
in the beginning divide and conquer so
there's strength in unity and then there
is divide and conquer these two concepts
are actually related they are just the
opposite now you know both of these
things can you now think of a way to
address this medical problem you may
pause this video for a second for a
maybe half a minute or minute however
long it takes uh many people actually
are not able to solve this problem but
if you're able to solve it great uh so
the solution is like this well you do
not point a single extremely powerful
Ray at the tumor rather you point a
number of rays from different directions
at the tumor so when they converge at a
single point on the tumor their their
combined power will be able to destroy
the tumor but because each of the Rays
themselves are weak and they're pointing
from the different directions when they
pass through the through the uh healthy
tissues they will not they're not going
to burn them
up okay so this is a very simple elegant
solution and you you can now probably
understand what is the connection with
those two sentences those two proverbial
sentences there is strength and unity
and divide and conquer there is another
step which I did not mention was that
although these are two opposite things
the way that I have used that those two
prover proverbial sentence information
in this problem is to actually think of
the message there in a slightly
different way so there the divide and
conquer thing was in a negative sense
but here I have uh done the opposite of
that I have done the divide and conquer
in a positive sense to do something good
for a human uh for for this medical
problem for a human being it is after
all the same thing okay the Deep
structure of this problem is directly
connected to that proverbial information
which you all know but you see how
difficult it is sometimes to transfer
from that abstract Thing by this double
inversion of the concept to this
concrete problem so when you uh when you
go through different kinds of examples
which which CHS your mind through uh
through the applications of these
various uh Concepts to various kinds of
concrete situations uh then you slowly
slowly develop this ability to uh to
understand uh abstract ideas
so it is not always good to just mug up
the the abstract things or to mug up or
maybe to just mindlessly go through
number of different examples rather it
is important to step back and try to
connect with these abstract ideas in a
very conscious fashion even if your
teacher doesn't do it you have to stand
back a little and try to make this type
of connection and it is only by this way
that you'll be able to to develop your
knowledge from something which is
shallow to something which is rather
deep which will enable you to appreciate
the Deep structure of apparently
disconnected problems the next thing is
something
which maybe a little bit unpopular again
like the like the stressing of the
memory and that is the importance of
practice now I may sound like a broken
record here uh telling you Grandpa's
Tales of how hard you have to work and
how much you have to practice and how
much you have to drill but again I want
to point out that this is not something
like a Grandpa's tale this is actually
backed up by evidence by research
evidence which has been carried out over
the last 20 30 years so what happened
was that in the United States a lot of
research has gone on on this and uh
education is there in the ' 80s they
came up with this uh well- meant very
very well-intentioned
idea that instead of making students go
through some kind of drilling and
practice maybe to develop to take them
towards problem solving it'll be good to
uh to expose them to something called
inquiry based learning or Discovery
method of teaching so these are very
these were very Buzz words in the in the
' 80s and '90s and even now some people
are still uh hanging on to those despite
uh evidence to the contrary this was
actually seen so those kids who were in
The were in the schools in the ' 80s and
'90s and the late '90s and early 2000s
when they went into college they uh it
was found that their performance had
actually deteriorated compared to the
previous generations of the students so
people again rethought and did more
research uh and they found out that no
it is actually the more uh structured
kind of although not the traditional
kind of uh Drilling which was done maybe
much earlier but uh something which is
uh backed by evidence if people do this
kind of practice then their performance
can actually improve and people have
done studies for this uh through various
control
groups different kinds of teaching
methodologies they have used and they
have found this so the point that I'm
trying to make here is is simple you
need practice it is quite uh
self-evident that you need practice to
develop a certain certain uh competence
in any kind of topic or any kind of
activity or development of skill that
much is a given you also need practice
to develop proficiency whether it is in
sports whether it is in studies whether
it is in musical skills you need
practice to develop a proficiency but
then do you need practice Beyond a stage
where it seems apparently that you are
not developing anything so your skills
have kind of plateaued or leveled and
you not developing really but your
teachers are still asking you to
practice what's the point of that well
if you keep on practicing what happens
is that this kinds the the the skills
the the information that you are working
with it gets embedded in your
long-lasting memory and earlier we have
already discussed how that helps when it
gets embedded in your longlasting memory
it gets starts getting organized into
various kinds of structures and then
when you kind of encounter new
situations you are able to load that
from your long-lasting memory and apply
them within the limited confines of your
working memory better so practice helps
to develop this long-lasting memory what
also happens is that it develops a
certain amount of fluency in your skills
what what is meant by that is remember
that sentence the sun rises in the East
how automatic your comprehension of that
thing was so this thing automatic it is
actually a technical term in in
education research so developing this
automaticity is absolutely dependent on
how much you have practiced it may seem
like well that's self-evident but well
no people have actually proved it
through proper scientific studies as we
have said in the in the context of the
importance of abstract
ideas if you keep on practicing beyond
your proficiency level what happens is
that the kind of connections it helps
develop in your memory memory it helps
you to
transfer abstract ideas from one
concrete example situation to another
concrete example situation and that is
one of the I mean the beginning of your
journey towards more advanced level
problem solving uh so there's a very
good example from chess actually so so
chess players uh if you show them a
chessboard like from the middle of a
game and then you remove the pieces and
you ask them to again bring back the
pieces to their to the positions which
they had seen for maybe half a minute or
so they'll be able to do it okay a
certain if you if you take a chess
player of a certain level of ability uh
like a professional people who go into
compet competitions and play they'll be
able to do it how do they do it okay it
seems like magic so many pieces are
there and they're able to recall it from
memory and they do it well they don't
actually do it from memory piece by
piece what they have what they have done
is basically they have chunked up that
information they have chopped up that
information they don't do it consciously
they have chopped up that information in
terms of the functional units of the
game so when they have shown some the
pieces the the pieces not arbitr said
but as part of an actual game in the
midst of it they can understand the
meaning of the different uh positions
and that it is that that they recall
from
memory okay as opposed to that they have
done this actual study that if they if
the if if an extremely experienced chess
player is shown a random uh pieces like
where the pieces should not be actually
as part of the rules of the chest if
they're just randomly scattered on the
on the on the board and then they it's
removed then they are simply not able to
bring it back to the actual pieces so it
is not something that they have some
superlative memory it is that it is just
that they understand the functional
organization of an actual meaningful
chess board any when you when you're
when you're are doing your practice if
you if you ever take my advice please
remember that you have to space out your
practice this also has been uh shown by
research the the importance of it so
instead of cramming in one long session
or one on on short birth of a of an
extremely energetic session you have to
space out your practice first of all the
benefit is that doing this almost mind
numbing practice is boring
so uh Professor Willingham words so if
you space it out it becomes less boring
furthermore it helps in better retention
of your skills finally I have not
forgotten that last sentence I am 32 and
my girlfriend is 13 so let me show you
the the uh the the context in which this
sentence was written so as you can see
the next sentence is can we still do
quests together or our or our levels too
far apart sorry kind of new to W so w is
a game it's World of Warcraft so uh
those of you who are familiar with this
game will probably already understand
what this IM am32 and my GF is 13 take a
moment to understand this those of you
who cannot let me show you the the an
explanation which goes further
down so this gentleman who had written
this he has he has given an update to
his previous statement thanks a lot guys
I picked her up from her middle school
earlier and we are going to go
questing up to this part it sounds
rather criminal okay 32 guy 32y old guy
because that is the Assumption we are
working
with uh picking up his girlfriend from
middle school because that is the
Assumption here for most of us but then
you see as soon as she has done grading
her student papers so actually what is
going on here if you have not already
figured it out is that this 32y old
man is not actually a 32y old man he's
just some age guy which we don't know
what his age is and his girlfriend is
actually a middle school teacher so
nothing inappropriate there the 32 and
the 13 are actually their levels in the
World of
Warcraft it is the levels so when we
when you start working with the wrong
assumptions when we do not have the
appropriate background information
because we completely lose the context
you see what happens so on that note one
final piece of advice is that since
background information is so very much
important and we need to be exposed to
different kinds of examples and our
ultimate Journey here the whole point of
this thing is that you can learn how to
learn
yourself so that you can proceed towards
the Journey of developing your
Proficiency in problem solving and you
can do that by first starting worked out
examples because just as we have seen
this there will be certain situations
where you'll will just not be able to
understand anything of what is going on
okay because you'll be working from the
wrong assumptions so you have to look at
the worked example which is the master
solution and only then you'll be able to
develop some kind of mental models for
yourself through which you can fall back
on your own abilities and uh develop
your own problem solving so when you are
learning something new go through an
worked out example go through the actual
discussions in the textbook and then
proceed towards problem solving if you
proceed like this only and only then
you'll be able to learn on your own and
start doing problem solving on your own
so this was a rather long video but I
hope you'll be able to take some
important take-home messages and really
start learning properly on your own so
all the very best thank you